whenever you pick up a new game you're
obviously going to encounter a learning
curve and depending on the game that
curve can be easy
i'm the greatest
gamer alive period or
it can be
infuriatingly treacherous hey someone
with the cc come in your lane
so in an attempt to make onboarding
noobs less painful most games offer some
form of tutorial which most of us skip
through as fast as humanly possible but
even if you do take the time to have
your hand held through the fundamentals
of a new game the truth is these guides
don't adequately prepare you for what
you're going to experience in a
competitive match
dude holy
holy
but of all the esports that
unceremoniously crap upon their newest
recruits
perhaps the worst offender
is counter-strike a 20-year-old treasure
trove of sacred knowledge spawned from
sweaty competition and painful
experiences a game that rewards
countless hours of grinding and seldomly
shines upon those who are
well
less seasoned
okay uh 1ct
they haven't
did you see that cs go's tutorial
teaches you the absolute bare minimum it
shows you the button you have to press
to shoot the button to crouch but it
doesn't teach you how to shoot it
doesn't teach you when to crouch and it
sure as hell doesn't teach you anything
about the intricacies of the in-game
economy utility usage spray patterns
where to stand where not to stand call
outs what a freaking jump bind is
the list goes on if you think about it
counter streak is a game that doesn't
really want you to play it i mean if
counter-strike's tutorial was a swimming
instructor it would take you out to the
middle of the bermuda triangle inject
you with an unknown substance throw you
into the water and whisper the word swim
of course you can play with experienced
friends but
even then
chances are
you're gonna to struggle
stop baiting your mates
it's all down to you
what do i do get in there
he's so far but fortunately for all of
us there is someone out there
who's tried to change all that and his
name
is brent but you all know him as the war
owl a head-clicking enthusiast turned to
cs samaritan who's been trying to better
the game's player base for nearly a
decade you're trash at counter-strike
but that's okay so how did this
altruistic bird of prey become the
beloved and trusted go-to for much of cs
go's player base why did his approach to
teaching earn him the ire of some
members of the community and after years
of subjecting himself to the content
grind where does he find the drive to
keep spreading his wings
[Music]
okay so before we get into the war owls
story or the story of the war owl if you
will
please take a second to like the video
subscribe to the channel and turn on
notifications hell even throw in a
comment if you want a million of them
might get us to make the video that you
want
like this one question mark alright so
if you've ever watched a war owl video
you know the signature greeting
greetings i the warowl greets you but
what you may not know is that he
actually has a number of interests
outside of saving the bacon of scrubs
all over the world for instance the war
owl is a man of refined taste it's just
a jalapeno
and he's known to enjoy a good meme is
this is this one of these optical
illusions where he's no
i was gonna say is this one of these
optical illusions where he's spinning so
fast
that it just looks like he's not
spinning on top of that the war owl is a
real stickler for consistency well
anyway guys i'm the warowl and i still
have no closer thank you folks very much
for watching i am the war animal and i
still
have no closer and he bears an uncanny
resemblance
to a cinema legend why do you look like
orson welles i think it's time finally
to
to let you in on a little secret
i am orson
the
welles
anyway like a lot of us the war owl
discovered gaming at a young age
initially his interest was purely for
entertainment but as he was introduced
to multiplayer games like team fortress
classic and eventually counter-strike it
became a competitive outlet and exercise
for self-development like myself wasn't
really into athletics and wasn't really
good at those sorts of things
gaming was something where i could
actually compete and have fun with it
and communicate with other people
because i've always been very shy and
kind of socially isolated and that sort
of stuff so gaming was a great way to
kind of um put myself out of my comfort
zone as well interacting with other
people and it was through those
interactions during a game of
counter-strike that brent first
discovered his now famous handle we were
getting absolutely owned the entire time
so i i tried to give a moving speech to
motivate my team i said men
we may be outnumbered
we may be outgunned
we may be outskilled but at least we
have the power
of morale
and then someone on my team said the
power of the war owl now from instances
like that the war owl came to realize
that there were a lot of people out
there playing counter-strike
without a hope or a prayer and so he
decided to help them out by sharing the
knowledge that he had gained through his
own experiences learning the game i was
really into starcraft 2 at the time so i
was watching the guys who were making
all kinds of content for that i was a
big fan of day 9 and the kind of stuff
that he was doing and i couldn't find
that for counter-strike so even though
like i wasn't the best player i was like
you know what i'm gonna just make some
of these on my channel and see how they
do now warowl wasn't a total newcomer
when it came to content creation
previously he had uploaded cooking and
minecraft videos but after releasing his
first cs source tutorial in 2011
his channel really began to take off
that's the kind of content once i
started making it it really blew up and
it did really well so as a youtuber when
you see that and you see the numbers and
the reaction and all the feedback that
people are giving it's like oh people
like this i should make more of this but
it was in 2012 with the release of cs go
that everything changed for the war owl
now if you weren't really paying
attention to counter-strike back then or
esports at large the release of cs go
was a big moment it had the potential to
unite the disparate 1.6 and source
communities while also building a new
esport in a moment where interest in
competitive gaming was rising
exponentially and for war owl this was
an opportunity to get in as the game
spun up
which is exactly what he did so what do
you guys think of the think of the beta
so far i think of the game
i like it a lot
yeah i like it better
but
if you keep in mind that it's a beta
then it's awesome while his early videos
included things like competitive
commentary and discussion of updates to
the game it was his educational content
that attracted the most eyeballs acting
as thorough introductions to the game's
core concepts warhol videos were
thoughtful conversational
and above all
informative the owl name might have been
a coincidence but this dude was dishing
out real wisdom the p250 is a good way
to put the cts back in a powerful
position and we all know how important
that first round is it usually
guarantees you the first three rounds
which is
very important improvement was at the
heart of why the warowl started his
channel but for him tutorials
were just the beginning as the arms deal
update launched cs go skins in 2013
warhol created his first unbox of
fragathon video where he would open a
case but then have to actually use the
skin in-game regardless of which weapon
it belonged to so that was originally
created as a parody of the kind of meta
that was going on at youtube at the time
was just posting case openings like oh i
have a thousand cases i'm gonna open
them that's my content so i was like oh
how can i put
how can i put an interesting spin on
this and kind of poke fun at that we'll
get an item and i will have to get 50
frags with that item it was quirky ideas
like the unbox of fragathon
and his smooth vocal stylings that first
built up the war owl's early youtube
presence making him not just an educator
but an entertainer what would you like
to suckle on your mama's tit a little
bit more before you go into the real
world what the [ __ ] is that he's scary
back in my day we didn't have any of
them fancy heculus
we used hard work and determination to
succeed oh crap
um
i don't know how to take the bomb out
i'll put you
down no i'm using a controller
oh hell i don't know through his
commitment to laugh and learn alongside
his audience the war owl's popularity on
youtube continued to blossom and with
his channel hitting a hundred thousand
subscribers by mid-2014 he was able to
quit his job as a software engineer and
fully dedicate himself to the content
grind this is the stupidest thing i've
ever done
but i have taken this opportunity now to
pursue my passion so i'm gonna have to
ask you guys for your support going
forward in the future because come july
you have got me
full time by the end of that year war
owl had become one of cs go's most
popular content creators and as a result
found himself being honored by valve
with an in-game sticker you can now put
a piece of this youtube channel on your
weapons in the game this is in actuality
the coolest thing to ever happen to me
i'm now in
my favorite game the game i've been
playing for 15 years the game i quit my
job to make videos about but as the war
owl opened himself up more to the cs
world in 2015
he also discovered that he wasn't
without his critics in particular the
now infamous op tutorial he made
attracted the attention of pro player
josh steele neeson who talked negatively
about it on stream the now deleted clip
circulated widely and the stop scope
flick fire refrain from the tutorial
became a meme of sorts
one stop moving
two
scope
three flick the crosshair to the enemy
and four click the left mouse button to
fire that stop scope flick fire
following steel's lead was pro player
ryan freakazoid aberdeer who felt the
need to further weigh in on the
situation dude you know why warowl says
all that [ __ ] guys let me give you you
want me to give you my honest opinion
even if i die i won't care
my honest opinion why someone wow gives
so much detail about stuff that he has
no idea about in the game don't
it's because it's his only way to make
money in the game but the criticism
directed the war owl's way was poorly
aimed from the beginning of his youtube
journey it was very clear that brent's
intention had not only been getting
people into counter-strike but enjoying
it he wasn't interested in turning them
into pro players and he sure as [ __ ]
wasn't interested in getting involved in
any sort of drama like legitimate
criticism i'm gonna look into it and
learn from it and try to improve from it
i do things i make like dumb typos in my
videos as well and people point them out
so um but like legitimate criticism i
think is important to look at and not
get too big-headed about but in terms of
drama and people trying to start
something i'm not interested in that i'm
not interested in engaging with it even
though the misplaced criticism created a
false narrative that his content was
purely quote for silvers
brent who is global elite i might add
continued to nurture his ever-growing
nest of followers while never taking
himself too seriously and along the way
his viewers learned a lot about him like
that he was into classical music nope
not gonna do it in this video but yeah
i'm interested in violin that he needed
some paternal affirmation
are you proud of me dad he wasn't or
that apparently he was into ronald
reagan which if you don't know stems
from his setup tour video where he
showed off a ronald reagan calendar a
recurring gag that he told us represents
both an inside joke and a mystery so i
don't know i get these calendars in the
mail i don't know why and like every
year i get a new ronald reagan calendar
i don't know who's sending them i'm like
on some list or something i don't i have
no idea so i just thought well this is a
strange item it's a calendar where every
month is a different picture of ronald
reagan so i thought let's just
incorporate this in a funny way into the
video it's kind of like this strange
like background meme i guess you could
say that someone sent him unsolicited
gip pics
oh shut up
anyway presidential tomfoolery aside
before he knew it the war owls channel
broke a million subscribers in 2017 but
it was clear that brent had grown
alongside his audience he went from
making jokes about his weight coke zero
tastes a lot better than diet coke and
i'm fat
to actually doing something about it
you've probably seen like the old videos
old content and what i used to i look
like a completely different person i
think i've lost i think it's at 60 to 65
pounds at this point i'm at my target
weight but most importantly he had
finally become more comfortable being in
the spotlight something that he
struggled with initially i've gone to
events and i've met the people who've
watched my videos and i've interacted
with all kinds of people and the first
time i did that was so
absolutely terrifying i had like a mini
panic attack uh i went to an event in
california and people on the plane
recognized me were like hey you're waro
and like my face was like flushed red
and stuff now in 2021 the war owls
channel is halfway to its next million
subs and thanks to the unprecedented
popularity of cs go his archive of
tutorials remains as helpful now as ever
and on top of finding new ways to enjoy
the game that launched his journey along
the way he hasn't been afraid of
continuing to spread his wings
where i get the most i guess growth the
most pleasure out of making something is
when those two meet when i make
something that is creative and i'm able
to push myself beyond what i'm
comfortable with and where the audience
really likes it as well so in the end
what is it that makes the war owl's
content so
vital he may not talk about himself a
lot but even so what shines through is
the fact that he like his viewers is
eager to learn and it's that hunger to
improve that set him on his path in the
first place but it also keeps him
grounded so that he can welcome more
newcomers into his flock i would say
that the best experiences that i've had
with doing war owl is meeting the people
who have watched my videos and it's
something i get to do very rarely
especially now with everything being
locked down
but
so i'm getting a little emotional
just like seeing people tell you that
just the goofy videos i'm making in my
basement has had a positive impact on
them that's been the most rewarding for
me regardless of where the war owls
content journey takes him next there's
no question that through his knowledge
and humor he's been able to help
countless people learn to love a game
that notoriously doesn't want to love
them back and because of his dedication
to growing alongside his audience it's
hard to imagine where the cs go
community would be today
without him
i failed
default
i'm out of bullets guys
oh wait i killed him
that was the stupidest round i've ever
seen
they thought i was one of them
well the strangest thing i've ever
signed
um was a young man's face
i didn't want to do it he was like no
you have to do this i said no i really
don't want to do this this is
this is a sharpie this is going to be on
you for a while i think there's a
picture out there of it so there's
warowl the way that i sign it on this
young man's face
and he i was at a tournament he had that
on there for the rest of it and i was
just like oh gosh i wouldn't have had
that done to me
oh my gosh it was yeah so i've signed
some very strange things people bring
like funny meme items sometimes to sign
so it's always an enjoyable experience